By the way, guys, I am testing, just so everybody knows,
a little side note, I am testing stuff all the time,
testing Yelp, testing Bing.
For those of you that are like,
well, what happens if Google does this?
Guys, I don't care.
Guys, the strategy is sending leads up front.
The strategy is providing results in advance.
The technique we're using right now is Google Ads.
If that shifts, if that gets more expensive,
that whatever, great, we'll go find something else.
If you have a site that does not have,
that already has leads coming in consistently,
you can skip the ads part, right?
Because the ads is, it's the leads that we're trying to get.
So if you don't have the leads,
you need to do the ads to get the leads, to get the deal.
But if you already had the leads, you don't need the ads.
So technically, you could go to Facebook Marketplace
and pay a VA to go scrape Facebook Marketplace
and get a bunch of leads,
and you could use those to close the deals, right?
Technically, that'd be a technique, right?
Strategies results in advance.
So just quick side note B is, yeah, I agree.
It's stupid, Google, whatever.
I'm always testing stuff because, like, but I don't care.
If Google shifts and it doesn't work as well,
then we'll change.
I'm testing stuff right now
because I would like to find something
that works better, that's cheaper.
And I'm hoping there's something out there
and I'll keep testing.
And as soon as, as you guys know,
as soon as I figure it out, I'll give it to you, okay?